il reste trois mois avant le premier
tour de l'élection régionale mais il
n'en reste qu'un pour s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales
cette année grâce à l'adoption d'une loi
par le parlement les citoyens ont
jusqu'au 30 septembre pour s'inscrire en
mairie
alors il faut apporter une pièce
d'identité carte d'identité ou passeport
en cours de validité et un justificatif
de domicile à votre non daté de moins de
trois mois
autre solution plus simple et plus
rapide l'inscription par internet le
ministère de l'intérieur propose une
plateforme spéciale permettant
l'inscription en ligne
pour cela il suffit de se connecter sur
le site mon service-public puis cliquer
sur l'onglet téléservices et complétez
le formulaire
ça arrive directement chez nous et on
reçoit sa carte électorale comme
n'importe pour n'importe quel
d'inscription donc pour cette année ce
sera début décembre le jour du vote il
n'est pas nécessaire de présenter sa
carte électorale une pièce d'identité
suffit c'est un droit c'est un devoir et
on peut pas laisser la responsabilité
aux autres de
des décisions politiques il faut
s'investir au moins en allant porter sur
la commune de montigny 24 milles 576
électeurs sont déjà inscrits sur les
listes pour la verrière ce sont plus de
3000 personnes un chiffre qui reste
stable comparé aux élections
départementales